comme la plupart entre vous j'adore
raconter des histoires à tel point que
j'ai déjà écrit deux livres
bon ok le premier fait vingt pages et le
second ont fait 50 jantes amélie j'ai
entamé l'écriture de mon premier livre à
l'âge de 15 ans il s'appelait les
voyages d'asthme à elle il racontait
l'histoire d'un jeune homme parti à la
recherche de sa maison perdue au fond
d'un volcan
mon second livre traité de la rencontre
d'un ingénieur et d'un pirate qui
s'unissaient afin de construire le
bateau le plus performant et partir à la
conquête du monde
à l'époque je trouvais ces histoires
extraordinaires
maintenant avec le recul je me dis que
j'ai bien fait d'arrêter ce que j'en ai
retiré c'est que serait pas une carrière
d'écrivain et qu'on était tous en
recherche d'un moyen de transcrire les
histoires et les partager avec le monde
alors j'y réfléchis un soir orange dans
des dossiers sur mon ordinateur j'ai
retrouvé un projet que j'avais fait à
l'école il traitait de l' usage des
réseaux sociaux par les jeunes
c'est un projet qu'on avait réalisé en
groupe on était tous issus de
nationalité et d'origines différentes
on a eu d'énormes difficultés à
s'accorder sur la direction à donner à
notre histoire
finalement nous avons tenu notre
convenable
j'ai donc réfléchir aux raisons de ce
succès l'écoutent et la co-création je
me suis dit farid là dessus c'est un
truc focus travaille dessus
donc j'ai écrit une phrase que j'ai
envoyée à tous mes amis par e-mail arles
en disant voici la première phase de mon
histoire à vous de la compléter les
retours furent intéressant allant de
quelques mots à plusieurs phrases afin
que la co création soit équitable j'ai
décidé d'y mettre des règles ainsi
66 stories est née 66 stories a pour
objectif de mettre la co-création au cur
notre créativité commune mais aussi
d'aller à la rencontre de l'autre à
travers leur histoire
il s'agit d'une application qui permet à
deux personnes d'écrire une histoire de
six phrases et de 6 mo
la première personne envoie une phrase
de 6 mo à la seconde qui la complète et
ainsi de suite
voici la première histoire que 66
stories récupérer il s'agisse de celle
d'hugo et de laura hugo être un expatrié
français qui vit entre tanger et paris
lowrie son ami l'histoire commence ainsi
un fermier blessés appel au secours
par chance et de garant temps son cri
ils accourent
une seconde explosion retentit lagrange
brûle les chevaux fui les choses seront
plus calme maintenant
merci gare mumure doucement le paysan
cette histoire est la rencontre de deux
personnes complètement séparées par la
distance mais unis par cette histoire
mais l'expérience s'arrête pas ici elle
continue car chaque histoire est donné à
une communauté d'artistes qui a pour
mission de lui ce trait l'idée de
construire un îlot créativité où chaque
acte est un axe d'action et non un acte
de consommation
d'ailleurs vous allez tous passer à
l'action car on va raconter une histoire
de 6 mo en séparant la blague en six
blocs
cela nous permettra en commençant par la
droite d'écrire une histoire jusqu'à la
gauche donc je demandais à la partie de
droite de me donner un mot allez-y alesi
n'ai pas peur alors à droite bateau en
faudra un début de phrase madame
ça m'arrange pas alors je ça me vient
très bien yahoo continue et la phrase
après jeu allez-y cette rangée ici je
construis avoue je construis une une
bulle je construis une pub du mouvement
cap avec et manque un dernier mot lipow
pardon je construis bull avec
imagination
c'est la première phrase de votre co
création à vous la continuer en
utilisant le hashtag des dix réunions
hashtag 66 stories merci